hey everyone eric boss here in the new
rockstars blue dungeon
and it is confirmed the fantastic four
marvel's first family is coming to the
mcu
information revealed to us by our lord
and savior kevin feige at disney's
investor day conference
not only is this coming we got
information that it will be directed
by spider-man far from home it's
spider-man homecoming and spider-man 3
director
john watts telling us so much about what
ideas they have for how this first
family's gonna get introduced into the
mcu
i'm just gonna give you my first initial
thoughts to this and my reaction because
i was blown away by this check it out
film about one of the truly iconic
marvel families in fact
marvel's first family fantastic four
fantastic four we'll work we'll get a
feature now and it will be directed by
the director of our recent spider-man
films
john watts they're giving it to watts
we've got a lot
of marvel studios all right um so there
wasn't much to react there because
feige just dropped it as if there was
nothing more to talk about there but the
fantastic for coming to the mcu folks
this
bury the lead that is the headline
coming out of this so the fantastic four
coming in mcu have been a long time
coming
we don't have a sense of who the cast
will be yet obviously a lot of people
want uh
john krasinski to play reed richards
emily blunt to play his wife sue storm
but before we even get to that we just
got a ton of information in the fact
that
john watts will be the one directing it
john watts this guy is brilliant he
made a spider-man homecoming spider-man
far from home having to work with
a lot two different studios worth of
notes uh and he made
two pretty solid films that are among
the funniest mcu installments that we
have
so that give us a sense of the tone of
this fantastic four movie it's not going
to be too super serious but it's going
to do such a good job with easter eggs
and fan service don't forget
john watts is a master of easter eggs
when it comes to license plate
numbers referencing comic issues he hit
a howard the duck easter egg
in spider-man homecoming that we new
rockstars me
was able to find uh and he tweeted us
good job
thanks john watts for tweeting back it
makes my life when that happens
but obviously at the end of spider-man
far from home we were given a
ton of fantastic four setup details
obviously
there are some new occupants of avengers
tower
they built this new atrium in there uh a
lot of people believe that the avengers
tower the mcu
is going to be turned into the baxter
building that is the headquarters of the
fantastic four
it just makes too much sense right if
avengers hq
has moved upstate why do they still need
the tower in the middle of manhattan
let's turn that into the shining beacon
of the fantastic four
the the people who are now going to be
the main lineup of the marvel heroes the
fact that he had
spider-man glide through that atrium
that has to mean
something right and of course there was
the sign on the on the street level
that said we are so excited to show you
what comes next one two
three question mark four a lot of people
thought it was just setting up
phase four and it probably was because
um you know
spider-man part for home was right on
the border between phase three and phase
four
but the number four you know there's one
thing that means in marvel it's the
fantastic four
the fact that those two images were
shown back to back uh in our
re-breakdown of the spider-man far from
home movie that we did over the summer
uh if you look closely at a lot of the
people on that atrium yes
some of them could be uh johnny storm
some of them could be reed richards sue
storm ben grimm
i feel like the fact that john watts is
being brought back to make this
fantastic four movie means that we might
see a shift in perspective of that same
moment of people getting lunch on that
atrium
looking up seeing the web slinger
gliding over their heads and they're
like
um but anyway the negative zone right uh
i have some theories that the negative
zone in the mcu
is just gonna be the quantum realm
because the way they have shown the
quantum realm in the mcu
it has all the properties of the
negative zone it's kind of this
banishment place that gives you strange
properties obviously janet van dyne
was uh given healing powers as a result
of being
in the uh quantum realm uh ghost
when she was hit by a blast of quantum
energy
that made her a phase shift why not give
you the powers of being able to stretch
your arms or turn invisible or
flame on or turn into a yellow rock turd
but i don't think the task of setting up
the fantastic four in the mcu is going
to be left
just on those final minutes so far from
home and on john watts
obviously all of these phase four titles
that we learned about at this conference
are working in tandem they're
interconnected and we
are seeing some elements of loki a
mysterious hooded figure who could be
doom we're seeing ant-man in the wasp
quantum mania my favorite new title we
learned about
that is gonna feature kang the conqueror
in the quantum realm
uh making that city most likely
chronopolis
unless they want to rename it quantum
mania i guess i wouldn't have a problem
with that the kang the conqueror is a
time
travel villain who deals with alternate
timelines one of the coolest villains in
all of marvel comics
and yeah you could see different ways
that that is set up as early as loki
with the tva and these alternate
timelines
maybe there's some code on those
elevator buttons what i personally hope
to see for a fantastic four
movie in the mcu is uh what peyton reed
pitched back in the day before
uh before he started working for marvel
in the ant-man movies was this idea of a
retro
60s flashback movie that shows you
marvel's first family as
stan lee originally brought them into
marvel comics they were a 60s swinging
family of heroes
and they were famous as some of the
first superheroes who did not hide their
identity they they walked around
no mask people knew them they were
famous around new york city
that could be a quartet of legacy heroes
who disappeared into the quantum realm
slash negative zone maybe back in the
60s
when uh hank pym was uh experimenting
maybe that was some accident uh
that's how he knew what the quantum
realm was to begin with uh
they disappear down there they go into a
time vortex they don't age and they come
back out in the present
day that's how you can get the fantastic
four in the present day mcu
they come back out in new york city
they're like hey our old building
i guess had new occupants in this tony
stark guy is he related
to howard stark who we knew uh and then
they they take back over that tower they
turn it back into the baxter building
and that that's a very seamless smooth
uh transition that we can see that won't
upset anyone because no one's taking
anything from anyone they're just taking
back what was theirs to begin with and
you get to see marvel's first
family in the 60s as they were in the
comics you get to see them in the
present day and yeah if ant-man 3
is dealing with uh kang the conqueror as
a time travel villain if you tie
in doctor doom with that all of these
characters can appear
in this fantastic four movie i think
john watts has a really good
handle on these characters i know people
have some issues with spider-man
homecoming spider-man far from home
it wasn't the exact toby version of the
character that they wanted i get it but
those two movies are
so funny and and nail so much about the
spider-man character and if john watts
can nail spider-man he can absolutely
nail the fantastic four i'm so excited
to see what this guy does with it i
hope to see them introduced in
spider-man 3 a movie that has
everyone in it so why not introduce the
fantastic four
as well with just a little easter egg as
peter parker and doctor strange
are zipping through the web of life and
destiny hey who are those for never mind
that save that for another movie and a
post credit scene
i'm obviously going to be digging way
more into this fantastic four news which
is so fantastic
um and check out our new rockstars merch
store new rockstarsmerch.com
for all the great new merch options a
lot of great gift options be sure to
watch my reactions to the loki trailer
to the one division trailer to falcon
winter soldier trailer and my breakdown
of all the big news we learned about
this is coming out
next and then a classic in-depth easter
egg breakdown of everything you missed
in this loki trailer shot by shot frame
by frame you know how we do it follow me
at evos follow new rockstars subscribe
hit that notification bell see you soon
[Music]
bye
you